growing up I used to read tons of
fantasy and science fiction books I read
all of Robert E Howard's Conan books
when I was 15 I met the guy who created
the Conan source for the movie and that
was instrumental in getting me into a
knife and sword making it was just
something I always wanted I wanted a you
know a knife or a sword I didn't have
the money to buy it so I i went home and
i made this machine and made my own
knives same thing with the armor i met a
guy at a Renaissance Faire I saw making
armor and he says it's a two-year wait
and five thousand dollars and so I
watched him work for an hour and went
home and replicated all of his tools
I'll be 50 this year and I've been doing
it every single day since I was 15 years
old being in Burbank I'm within three
miles of Disney Studios Warner Brothers
NBC and universal initially I was
working at a lapidary shop that I made
machinery for cutting gemstones and the
adjoining property was a prop house and
they asked me to bid on a project and
end up making some sculptures for a
theme park and eventually that same
contact referred Michael Jackson's
costumers to me where I made armor for
him and other accessories and the hook
for the movie hook and that was in my
early 20s I ended up being the armor to
the stars it's kind of wild